good evening we now
live good morning good afternoon
everyone my name is Vincent G I'm the
director general of the ftth council
Europe um the host of of this session
today uh so welcome to this webinar
titled Global policy and regulation
review organized by the fiber to the
home Global
Alliance um before I introduce you to to
our panelist I would like to to run
through a couple of uh housekeeping item
that will also give time to more
attendees to to join us I can see that
uh many of you are still logging in so
very practically this webinar is
recorded and we will send and share with
you a a link to to the replay so you'll
be able to to share that with others and
uh watch again at your lat leure um you
you've accepted to be on the call So you
you're likely to receive a communication
and invitation to additional event we
organize
online um we are very happy to take
questions but to do so you need to use
the question box which is located at the
bottom of the control panel uh you you
certainly have in front of you so don't
hesitate to to use this question Bosque
I will relay your question to to the
panelist towards the end of the session
and if we are not able to take your
question we'll address that uh
separately you um probably wonder what
uh fcga mean uh and it stands for uh
ftth Council Global Alliance it is
actually a um
unal um alliance between um trade
Association having in common uh the
objective to promote the acceleration of
fiber to the home adoption and roll out
across our respective
regions and um The Alliance is composed
of six uh
Association starting with digital
Council Africa based um I think
headquarter in in uh in South Africa and
covering subsaharian Africa fiber
Broadband Association uh represented
here today by Gary uh looking after um
the US and and Canada and with its Latin
America chapter um represented by
Eduardo um who is covering all the um
well the southern part of of of that big
part of the world uh Latin American
countries we also have in the network
five fiber Network Council APAC for Asia
Pacific region and another similar
organization covering Middle East and
Northern Africa fiber connect Council
Mina and I'm uh in charge of um the
European side of things with ftth
Council Europe so we're very happy to to
have you on this uh on this session as a
as a group we are meeting on a regular
basis we are sharing best practices we
also working on a couple of project in
common and today we are very happy to to
share with you um the the high level
results of a our latest white paper uh
called Global policy and regulation
review and you can directly download
this asset uh from uh the webinar from
the handouts uh section on the control
box you can have access to the PDF uh
document so I encourage you to directly
download it you will also find the the
document from um the website of each of
the organization I've just listed so
don't don't hesitate to to to go through
that the objective of the call today is
really to enable panel our panelists to
to share their comment on the key
chapter we are covering in this document
what we wanted to do is to emphasize on
something fundamental for the
development of f Network throughout
Europe which is the
policy um and Regulatory framework which
um set the context for an health growth
of ftth deployment this is what can
drive um private investment this is what
enables competition between stakeholders
and and operators and ultimately
facilitate the acceleration of the
deployment of fiber in the different
region so understanding the difference
uh between region between countries is
quite interesting and important for
whoever wants to to understand the
dynamic playing glob
for the ftth
market and with that I would like to
introduce you to to our panelist
starting maybe with Franco cordino we
are very happy to to have you uh on the
call Franco your head of unit investment
in high capacity Network at the European
commission uh and your based in Brussel
so very happy to to have good morning
good
afternoon
pleasure and Gary Bolton uh is president
and CEO of the fiber Broadband
Association and you're calling from
Alabama I think that's
right and Eduardo is the one enjoying a
nice weather um short leaves and and
sunny uh outdoor
temperature Florida yeah thank you nice
to be here thank for invitation Vincent
thank you so much uh we had a similar
session earlier uh today uh with my
colleagues from um Asia Pacific from um
Middle East and also from South Africa
so we we went through a similar uh
discussion but I think the the content
will will be a little bit um adjusted to
the reality of um the speaker lineup we
have today also the time zone because
it's mostly about maybe comparing the
situation between Europe and situation
between uh with with uh North America
and and Latin America so without further
Ado let me open the first chapter for
today which concerns um legal and
Regulatory
framework um why in first first and
starting with why does it matter what
what why is policy and regulation
important um the review clearly
highlighted uh the fact that um
there are a variety of situation and
complex regulation framework and policy
which govern the deployment of enti
ofation network we see a variety of
situations some regions like Europe are
have a overarching uh and centralized uh
regulatory framework which is somehow
imposed to member states um other area
of the world and I guess Eduardo that
will probably be the case you describe
for Latin America are much more
scattered and and and the situation is
extremely diverse country by country and
then you have the case of of the US that
Gary will uh will comment on um and so
the regulatory framework is also
dependent on um the deployment Target
and what policy maker want to to do what
is their objective and there again in
the review we we took stock of the the
variety of situation in the different
country um concerning learning how
government set and what type of Target
is set by government to or by a
political organization Regional
organization um to to ensure that
citizens get access to the highest level
of connectivity so if we open this
chapter I would maybe ask uh Franco to
to start by sharing uh y Comm and Franco
on European uh commission objective when
it comes to um bringing uh high capacity
Network to to the maximum number of
European Citizen and what are the key
regulatory framework that are put in
place to facilitate uh achieving this
target you you're on mute
Franco thank you uh Vincent indeed you
depicted the European situation very
well I mean it's not that we are
imposing to member states uh uh uh any
specific uh regulatory you know
regulation or or or directive or
whatever I mean it's it's you know the
the way governance works in the union
it's the commission that makes proposal
and of course if they are adopted voted
by the Council on one side which means
the member states themselves and the
Parliament on the other s then this
enters into Force this is I guess
slightly different than the other region
um uh but it seems to work somehow of
course at the starting point 20 years
ago in the union was that we had a
number of you know big incumbent
monopolies all over around and then we
started to uh liberalize the the market
and of course this requires of course a
good deal of regulations various layers
of regulation for some while we
proceeded kind of with the spatch
working and then at point in time we
said okay we have to hard harmonize all
of these and we did the European
electronic communication code that
everyone knows it's quite a good
reference but of course there are a
number of site also um regulations that
we do that are actually uh hooked very
well into the code
uh two of those of those we are just
working on we are in the last step
before being voted in the coming weeks
or few months now of course starting
from the targets that you said normally
we set targets and we do that every more
or less 5 to 10 years we had the target
for 2010 and we had the target for 20120
you remember digital agenda for Europe
then we had our targets for
2025 the gigabit Society targets and now
we have a targets for digital decade
which means end of this decade
2030 uh concerning fixed connectivity
really yes our aim is to really reach a
kind of universality for gigabit so
meaning every household in the union
being covered by 5G uh sorry by by
gigabit speed very high capacity
networks which is uh let's say a neutral
way to say in most of the cases fiber
but of course we due to the fact that in
in Europe we have a different type of
geographical situations very challenging
areas to reach on top of the mountain we
of course admit that other Technologies
can be used to achieve the gigabit um
targets now if you ask me what are the
challenges in all of these of course
first is yes this universality character
of this target uh could make it very
expensive but public is there also to
intervene when when necessary we have
plenty of programs for that um there is
a big issue which is perhaps the
elephant in the room the virtual room
and the fact is that the private
investive they see returns and for the
time being I mean actually I remember
last last year in Madrid we discussed
this very
extensively even in your your uh uh in
several of your the sessions there there
is a weak Demand on people don't
recognize at least here in Europe the
importance of moving to fivr because
fivr would guarantee a lot of property
symmetry low latency Etc which will be
absolutely needed for the future
application so if we want to really be
ready for the for the future we need to
go for ultimate Technologies which is
which is fiber the question is by when
and with which money that is the big
problem so challenges there really um in
Europe the fact we have a lot of legacy
and people might still sit in the
comfort zones The Operators to exploit
as much as they can their copper based
Technologies cables or vdl or whatever
it is and therefore we are there to
accompany this process which will take
time and uh with do uh po policies and
also uh regulations and of course
investment but we will speak in detail
about these in the next
rounds well thank you very much Franco
um maybe moving to to Gary um Target
importance of uh policym and Regulatory
framework what's the situation is in the
US well I mean it's just an amazing time
here in the US uh for fiber deployment U
you know this is past year uh we ended
up
51% of the US is now covered with fiber
so we've made great strides and setting
another um another record deployment
year 9 million homes passed in one year
beating the previous record the year
before at 8.3 million and so kind of
just as I'm sure Franco saw in Europe uh
with the Corona virus it really um kind
of emphasized the need for Broadband to
everybody and so what we saw a lot of
legislation come out of the US and
things called the car's act also the
American Rescue plan which were some
initial infrastructure money that was
gone that went out that really got
things going we had existing programs
the um us uh Department of Agriculture
has a rural utility service and R Us and
so that um has a reconnect program and
that's been going strong um that's a lot
of investment in fiber and then also the
FCC traditionally had some failed
programs one was called The Connect
America program which basically they had
speed parameters where it was um
initially the target was uh four
megabits Downstream one megabit upstream
and then they subsidized the same areas
all over again for 10 megabits one
megabit and then they subsidized the
same areas again for 25 Megs down three
up so they kind of just chased um the
DSL technology iterations and so they
launched something called the rural
digital opportunity fund
um which was initially going to be $20
billion I think about 7 billion got
distributed um and then really what's
happening now is the um what we call the
ntia bead program and this is part of
the bipartisan infrastructure law that
was uh President Biden signed into law
about two years ago and this is
42.455985 infrastructure for broadband
and uh so where that's the priority is
on fiber and so that's where we're
seeing a lot of investment in fiber um
so if I add all these up you know we are
seeing about 5x our normal um run rate
on federal subsidies for Broadband right
now and uh so this is going to add up to
somewhere in close to about a hundred
billion dollar uh and then we're also
seeing some similar number on private
investment because as we're building up
in the US it's a little bit different
than Europe because of the regulatory
environment favored cable for so long
and cable has dominant market share
where it doesn't in Europe and so the
cable operators are now having to
upgrade to fiber to compete um you know
with the so anything that's on new build
cables putting out fiber and anything
where there's in competitive areas
they're putting fiber so the goal of the
administration is to have every American
to have access to highspeed broadband by
the end of the decade and so we think in
the next five years we'll deploy as much
fiber as we deploy throughout history
and we'll get largely our way to being
able to connect every American with
fiber and how is Define high speed uh
Gary if I may ask is it a a certain is
it gigabit is it uh what is the
definition what are we talking about it
precisely well that's a political
football and unfortunately uh the
politic policians like to um use speed
as a proxy and so you know some of the
programs like for instance uh part of
the coronav virus investment was
something called uh the capital projects
fund that was funded by US Department of
Treasury so I had Joey wer this last
week on fire for breakfast who is
responsible for that1 billion dollar
about nine n billion has already been
allocated another billion left to go and
uh the speed on that is 100 Meg by 100
Meg which is the proxy for
on the bipartisan infrastructure law um
and when it got into you know basically
um conference and negotiations that went
from 100 by 100 down to 100 by 20 uh to
help out um Wireless and cable and
so luckily ntia put a hard preference on
fiber and so basically um the only every
project that's going to be for
infrastructure has to be fiber unless
it's over a extremely high cost
threshold and so every state gets to
Define what this number is and so if
it's just so ridiculously expensive to
reach a home with fiber they can choose
to look at some other Technologies but
um fortunately the preference is fiber
and you know when we look at the
investment you know we're the country is
trying to build the critical
infrastructure for the future where if I
look at the old FTC programs that failed
it was because they were Was a Race to
the bottom because they were you know
looking at speeds you know when they say
okay four megabits by one well that
sounded like a lot of broadband back in
the day but you know pretty quickly four
megabits doesn't do anything for anybody
right and then when you go to 10
megabits then that you know so now that
we're you know in the US the primary F
home deployment is with xgs Pond 10 Meg
symmetric I'm me 10 gig symmetric and
then we've seen seen 25 gig Pond being
deployed um Chattanooga is all 25 gig
Pond um we're seeing 18 others deploying
25 gig and then we're going to get the
00 gig terabits and so using speed as a
proxy is a I like to say one of my
friends Chris allly likes to say uh uh
broadband's about people and when it's
not it's about politics and that's where
we kind of get in trouble with the
politics
okay um so um maybe moving to you
Eduardo
um how would you address the same
question um with such a complex
um sub region you you're you're looking
after yeah of course well it's good it's
good to mention as you I before that uh
the Dynamics here in in the region um
you know we we we have different
approach in terms of Regulation and laws
regarding telecommunications um that
varies in per country right the
different approach all for sure that
follows the the same goals uh regarding
increasing penetration um um deploying
um cost efficient infrastructure uh to
connect to connect the population uh
neveress we we we we we may say that uh
some countries are doing better than
others right so which is the the
standard thing so I would approach first
um would address I'm sorry first the the
momentum in in in the region which is
pretty pretty aligned with what gu has
has described the momentum in the region
has been really interesting the last
four to five years here here in the kala
region despite the the the
microeconomics and and and and you know
uh you know social things happening you
know continuously in in different
countries but the the momentum uh
building networks has been really really
good we we currently have uh cting in
the last uh picture we took back in the
end of
2022 uh Latin America has roughly
around1 million of subscriber of
household uh um um connected to a any or
to a technology to a bro technology or
with a waran subscription uh and um half
of that uh let's say connection rate
connection rate is uh being made by by F
ftth right which is a a a good let's say
market share for for ftth nevertheless
we still having a lot of uh Legacy
infrastructure maybe as our colleague in
in euru mentioned uh we still having uh
a lot of legac infrastructure there in
the field and need to be you know
upgraded and and and and and moved to to
to fivr uh other other import import
aspect before addressing you know the
the regul the important regulation
things in in in in the region being
impacted by by regulation is um
household without any ftt age uh or fix
a let's say fix a br subscription we we
are roughly around 40% of of a household
in the region still without
a a proven connectivity right so uh
again a lot of uh um Legacy
infrastructure there a lot of room to
grow for penetration of course that
maybe from business case perspective not
all all of this 40% of of the of uh
areas to be covered are commercially you
know um feasible but uh there is when
you know regulation and and public
private initiative comes um to to
support that um that uh that deployment
so uh in the region of course as I
mentioned we we have different uh um uh
approaches in terms of Regulation and
different uh Targets in terms of uh
deployment we have for instance cases
like in Brazil uh um that uh in 2018 the
government launched the national ban
plant right and they aim to to to deploy
fiber to cover um 70% of the of the
households in Brazil by 2023 and this is
the the plan right if we look at our
numbers in the in the in the Panorama um
we foresee because we don't have the the
the final numbers for Brazil but we
foresee that Brazil fora will be uh
above the 70% of of a coverage by the
end of of 202 was by the end of 2023 so
they're doing quite well because of the
of the the you know the ecosystem they
have with many tile three and four
players large um T1 and T2 player so um
the Brazil has a a good momentum in
terms of of of f we have the case of
Mexico as well uh with the national
digital strategy um with the
goal of deploying 70% of of the market
they are a little bit lower um but the
this goal is set by 2024 we we think
that they are in in a good way to to
make it happen Chile is a is a very
mature market in terms of ftth lot of
operators and and and infrastructure are
are are in the in the already deployed
in the field and their objective um with
the with the the current program they
have for ftth is to have by
2025 100% of the of the population being
covered or the household being covered
with fiber optical infrastructure and
they they in in a very good way to to
have this this this metric uh
accomplished uh just to close Colombia
as well with the with the POR of of the
um Ministry of information Technologies
and communication they have the 70% as
go the 70% of the household to be
connected um um by
2022 and Argentina Argentina doesn't
have a let's say um a a goal in terms of
penetration in terms of coverage but
despite again the microeconomic the
social thing happening there and and
everything uh the the technology is
pushing very hard um to move uh towards
fiber and and government has has
launched through Universal funds and
other other incentives you know programs
to to to promote the deployment of of
the F so again just to close the the the
situation in in Latin America uh is
really good in terms of um maturity for
an for emerging economies as we have in
in the region uh but still lot lot lot
of things to be done uh in terms of
deployment to to face the let's say the
full uh penetration of FD in the region
well thank you very much Eduardo and
actually uh that offers me an
interesting transition to to the the ne
the next part which um is uh funding an
incentive because we covered uh targets
objective you already touched uh Gary
and yourself on on the importance of fun
funding as being at the core of
government policy I guess the the key
question around funding is where the
money should come from um or if it comes
both from private and public how do we
manage the right balance how do we make
sure that Public Funding is used where
it's most efficient uh how do you make
sure that it doesn't distort competition
and um maybe um make private investor
less um a bit reluctant to to to invest
so how do we manage that um that funding
mechanism maybe starting with again with
you Franco uh explaining a little bit
how um things are orchestrated at the EU
level um attracting private money but
also using public fund when uh when
necessary my microphone first so indeed
thank you for the interesting question
van uh uh we have a general you know
principle that of course we let the
market uh developing with its own forces
but of course we are conscious that
there are areas so-call market failure
areas where nobody would invest if the
public would not intervene there are
high risks that those populations will
remain cut out of the the digital trans
formation no connectivity no digital
transition um therefore of
course uh we are in general not
intervening so we don't want to crowd
out private Investments at the same time
we don't want the private to sit on
their their their comfort zones
so in Europe we have plenty of of
measures for that so first of all um we
have the programs we have the recover
and res resilience facility where a
consistent percentage of uh the fund uh
were devoted by the member states to
connectivity fixed or mobile we have
also included 5G of course we accepted
those Investments only if they were
supporting our common goals uh so
gigabit connectivity for all households
and 5G coverage in all populated areas
um we have the EUR the European Regional
Development Fund which you have by the
way mention in your report we have the
agricultur fund as well which also allow
for investing in rural very rural areas
with including with the with the fixed
infrastructure like fiber um we have the
invest guarantee that is managed by our
uh European Investment Bank and also all
the implementing Partners the National
Banks and any other pillar assessed
um uh implementing partner um so uh
we really try to complement uh uh the
the the efforts that the P private
sector is already doing uh we have a
regulation which is conducive to
Investments by definition so the code as
I said is is one of the objectives is
really to create a favorable conditions
for investment for co-investment ETC of
course um sometimes we have to intervene
more or less directly we have the
directly managed programs like the
connecting Euro
facility uh and we also have our own
financial instruments a form of public
partner part public private partnership
where basically we put the the as anchor
investors the so-called first loss piece
with an over goal to the risk the
investment so those investments in
infrastructures are typically relatively
secure investment with a relatively
manageable risk um and with this quite
certain returns but of course they are
more for patient investors so you need
to to have a long-term Prospect
perspective when when so typically
Pension funds of course they could be
interested in that actually in our uh
fund which is called European Broadband
connecting Europe uh Broadband fund we
have a put 100 million we got basically
a leverage of five time five to six
times uh by putting also investment from
the in
Investment Bank three National
promotional Banks and institutions and
the private the private investors so
it's a very good fundraising this one
for connectivity I would say and those
are project where that by definition can
be only in in market failure areas where
of course there the idea is that the the
use of um of the first piece by the
public by by by us is the the function
there I mean the um the the rational for
that is that it will unlock then in the
end the market and in the end we D
invest they divest and of course then
the market takes off even if it is in
rural areas because in the end you can
have a lot of uh of uh use cases and
also including for business use or for
supporting service of general interest
um in those remote areas so this is
basically the the quite wide pool of
that we do at European level of course
very often the challenge is to
coordinate all of this we have updated
recently our state a rules uh for
Broadband that of course allow sometimes
intervening in the in the presence or
the absence of course of a apprpriate
level of
connectivity um we for that purpose we
have divided the the territory into uh
white spots gray spots gray areas and
black areas just to
to see when there is a presence of one
at least Network or is it even planned
in the coming years um then we don't
intervene generally if there is one or
two Etc so there are different policies
for the different um different uh type
of areas and so far it works very well
on these in fact we see we see in our
annual uh digital decade report that uh
faiber roll out is progressing
relatively well the big problem that we
have is on the take up as I said but
that's a another
story thank you so much Franco uh Gary
you were mentioning very impressive
amount of public money being uh put on
the market for for fiber
deployment is it you know
[Music]
having a market failure can you tell us
a bit more about how that money is
channeled through to effective uh
operational
deployments yeah so the big money this
year is the uh the Niti be money and uh
that's Broadband equity and deployment U
money so that's infrastructure money uh
so while that was appropriated by um
Congress and administrated by one of the
agencies in Washington the money flows
down to all 50 states and six
territories so 56 States and territories
and so the way that money is allocated
is based on updated FCC mapping and so
before the FCC Maps were a disaster they
were um zip code postal code base and so
if you serve one location in a postal
code you were saying the whole area code
was covered which was a disaster and so
now it's location based so they um
commission cost Quest and done a much
better job on that and so the priority
is going to what we call unserved and
the definition of unserved is um less
than 25 megabits Downstream and three
megabits upstream and then the secondary
priority is on underserved and that is
if you have less than 100 megabits
Downstream and uh 25 megabits upstream
and so um or excuse me 20 20 megabits
Upstream so the so really gives a a lot
of opportunity there's also match you
know 25% match letter credit there's a
lot of parameters in place uh the nice
thing about the US is that we have a
tremendous number of models that have
come across you know kind of
traditionally you had incumbent
operators that had a what we call a
propensity to spend model so they would
basically put the investment in what we
call NFL cities so places you know big
um cities with people would have large
large disposable income so that was a
priority and so now by being able to um
with Corona virus and this whole need
for everybody to have Broadband uh what
we've seen is communities step up you
know saying hey we need Economic
Development we need jobs we need um
Access to worldclass Health Care
education so all those things that fiber
delivers those communities have stepped
up and so that's like you see someone
like Chattanooga um where they use the
utility of the community Municipal
utility or Rural Electric co-ops those
utility operators and then we see a lot
of new entrance into the market so we
have a lot of different models from the
tier one operators incumbents to tier
two and tier three to electric companies
to community Broadband to um new
incumbents you know the Google fibers
and so forth so a lot of players we have
about over 1100 fiber operators across
the US and uh so it makes it uh attract
a lot of private investment because if
you are were able to secure money to
serve an unserved Community the people
that need it most as you're trying to
get from your existing Network to there
you're passing lots of other
neighborhoods that are that might not
have fiber they might have okay service
but they're you know subject to some
other you know whether it's a DSL or
cable or fixed Wireless or something
else and they're able to now fiiz all
your there the other big area is tribal
communities um if you look at our we
have a committee um at fiber Broadband
Association on um tribal broadband and I
mistakenly had thought of tribes as like
um rural low income areas and as they
say if you met one tribe you met one
tribe and tribal areas are completely
different and there's some unique money
for tribal Broadband um from the
government that doesn't require mat so
there's lots of ways to kind of put this
money together to uh make it attractive
for private
investment okay thank you very much you
want to say allow me to to Gary because
you mentioned interesting you know we
have similar you know type of categories
of of uh of areas or communities where
we Our Roots tell us if we can intervene
or not with the public funds my question
to you is if you have any mechan is for
um for surveying uh with the stakeholder
because even if you have an un served
area you might have one or two or few
operators including loga that might have
already an intention or a plan to bring
fiber there uh how can you make sure
that you you know you are aware of this
you must probably have some survey in
place or and the second point is a
proposal to vanan is why we don't try to
have then a dedicated session in
checking each other let's say mapping
approaches to mapping and also surveying
these kind of things in whether we can
learn from each other yeah I mean the
one thing you know about mapping is it's
never right so it's um it's a never
ending challenge so basically the way
that the new FCC mapping it's basically
has two components first is the fabric
where they've identified all the
locations and then the second is
service provider data so each all the
The Operators Across the Nation um
provide their data on where they're
serving so that and that's constant so
you can constantly see uh what areas are
being served there's also a challenge
process so when you go to a w areas then
someone who might be planning to deploy
there already deploying can then
challenge saying hey I'm already
deploying this area so you don't need to
overbuild this so there's a lot of kind
of mechanisms in place to you know
because as any operator if they're going
to put investment in area they don't
want someone else coming in and and you
know taking away from their market share
um so these there's mechanisms in place
to make sure that um everybody knows
who's investing in the area and uh to
make sure that that money is going to
areas that are not being invested
in
okay thank you just want Eduardo to to
say a few words about uh financing do do
you say uh when we had the session this
morning um and I think I quote some of
the speaker from Middle East Africa um
they were saying that a lot of
deployment is very much dependent on a
company uh controlled by government and
and it's government investment and and
not too much relying on market dynamics
so not offering a lot of opportunity for
private investors do you have similar
situation in Latin America or on the
contrary do you see see a lot of uh
private initiative uh being um
responsible for the for the deployment
of
fiber no I I would say that most most of
the deployment here in the in the region
are conducted by PRI private R
investment okay uh we I may say that
we we have this
um this uh let's say um National
Broadband plans in place in most of the
major
countries uh and and with that um let's
say the public uh part of of of of the
discussion you know they outline some
specific goals and and they Pro propose
of or Define funding uh mechanisms and
and strategies to to SP you know explow
and and span the the the the Broan
access and and the Broan market right
and that that's included ftth of course
uh but basically
the the investment is being conduct by
by the private right side of of the
business we also have for sure for those
as as um Gary was mentioning the
underserved areas which is as I was
mentioning before a big portion of the
market to be you me deployer or upgrade
with fiber technology um that a big
portion of that big portion is maybe is
not attractive in terms of uh in terms
of um commercial you know product to be
to be sold in that in that market so uh
that
when
uh mechanism of funding from government
from the public side comes in and for
instance we have the Universal Services
fund which basically um these are are
this money that is financed by by
Telecom operators now and can be used to
subsidize the the deployment of of BR
infrastructure right um and we have for
instance in argena we have the nonre you
know a program that is a nonrefundable
fund that where where you as a as a
private you present a
project for Rob and roll out and that
will impact in underserved you know
ER population um you know you present a
product and they you know Grant you uh
money to to build that infrastructure in
a nonrefundable approach right so um but
answering your question the situation
here we have the maor you know operators
such as you know telica uh americ mobile
um um milon Liberty uh most of them the
fiber and they I would say that covers
um I don't know maybe 70 to 80% of the
market are being covered by by private
right the bigger big big players in in
the private side and we also have other
very large operators such as
CCTV uh Mega c um CNT Intel I don't know
many others Telecom argen cha uh many
others uh the new entrance I don't know
if we will be covering that further but
um the the new entrance for for the
regions are the the neutral you know the
neutral operators that are being funded
by um by Equity Funds or or or or other
other source of of funding and you know
they're pulling money to invest first
buying infrastructure and then spand
that infrastructure in fiber uh to to
allocate these resources to be to be um
to be rented basically by by by the
operator right so again most of the
investment has been made by by so far by
by private here yeah and I think it's
you offer me a perfect transition
Eduardo I think we um in in the program
uh in the in the in the document in in
the review we are also covering uh
things like competition policy
infrastructure sharing uh and the other
side of the infrastructure sharing is of
course uh operator model some of them
being wholesale based and uh really
offering a service to um of of fixed
infrastructure to uh ISP to
infrastructure to to information service
provider um so that market Dynamic is
also um also somehow regulated or uh
operates within a certain framework of
Regulation and there are also
consideration still in the review around
how um operator can have access to
public assets and all the question of
Permitting and making sure that there
are not too much administrative hurdles
when it comes to having access to public
asset in order to roll out so I suggest
to finish the the session that we
combine these two topics of um how do
you uh ensure a uh optimize Co operation
SL competition between Market players to
encourage investment but also to make
sure that money is not used um for
unefficient overbuilt which ends up with
too much money being invested for a
result which is not necessarily an
optimal coverage um and I guess on on
this question um maybe uo can you maybe
continue to elaborate on the situation
in Latin America before I pass the the
floor to to the other
speakers yeah sure sure Vincent well um
of course that um the regulatory
framework you know take the step here
and and and and you know to cover some
interest interest in in in in the in the
public side in for for for the for the
user for the consumer side as well um uh
and of course um the promotion ER of of
of this Market liberalization let's say
is is very important in in the region
again it's a
very diverse region in terms of
approaches we we do see um um this major
let's say just to put a a a an example
as an example uh in the region uh we we
we have this uh what I was mentioned
this neutral operators uh taking place
in taking the stage I mean in in in in
in mayor the mayor economies let's sayil
Colombia Argentina Chile Peru um and you
know with with the with the with the
with the goal to become the the major uh
the major player in terms of
infrastructure right with a with a
different let's say business model
implies a different approach in terms of
of of Regulation and conditions so I I
may say that um um the the biggest let's
say um uh or the key aspects to address
that are being addressed for these major
countries in the region that are
promoting you know the the evolution of
this neutral are you know again the
market Liberation right um is about
um avoid uh or take a take a take a look
on on on on you know activities or or or
merge that could you know drive to to
the
monopolization of the market you know uh
the other thing is um setting the rules
uh and guidelines to promote fa Fair
competition or prevent anti uh
competitive behaviors and and protect
again the interest of of the consumer
um the regarding this anti- comparative
practice um this uh practice include uh
looking at uh
um you know initiative that could imply
predatory pricing uh collusion abuse of
a dominant Market position um you know
um or to bury
ER the the new entries to to the market
Market you know um and finally um to
promote the the
interconnection and the access to the
infrastructure we we have some cases uh
where you know this
um uh you know the the the the
allowances of of a of of infrastructure
that has been deployed before for one uh
operator is mandatory I mean you you you
have to put that infrastructure
uh in in you know available for for your
competitors uh even though you are not
um your your core or your business is
not the the neutral approach um and in
the other in other countries you have
this um the government facilitating that
but not imposing that condition so again
different and and and diverse Dynamics
in in the region but again um I would
say that a main character in in in Latin
America and I was Focus maybe more in in
South America is is a nure operator and
and the role that they will take in in
the future
of thanks thanks so much Ardo um Gary a
similar question um how is uh
competition policy uh what is the role
of do you have infrastructure sharing
and maybe a few words on um access to to
public asset permitting is it also
something which can be a burden for for
operators yeah so as I mentioned earlier
we have a number of models that are
deployed across the US um so we do have
open access models in certain
communities uh where you know like for
instance uh Utopia fiber is uh and like
I think 19 communities and the
municipality buys that puts in the fiber
infrastructure and an ISP share that
infrastructure and there's a whole bunch
of different models of that uh it's so
really kind of it's a case-by case basis
based on what works for different
communities um but there's nothing
that's um mandated or you know I would
say Universal it's um you know every
area is a little bit different and
there's a lot of
flexibility on the area permitting is a
huge issue um so and I'm sure that
Franco will talk to this as well but um
we have Federal permitting and there's a
lot of work to try to streamline that
there's um a number of a lot of
legislation in the house
um you know in Congress right now so
Energy and Commerce Committee is working
on that uh but the problem is that
permitting is also at the state and
local levels and then we also have
Tribal lands and um you know land um
other areas that um you know we go over
different jurisdictions so just getting
everybody on the same page is very um
challenging and costly um same thing
goes with rways and attachments and you
know the the cost that different
communities charge to go across right
aways um the other area I would
highlight is locates um the Telecom is
probably the largest has the largest
loss from not having proper locates
where people um backo up you know
whether it's gas pipes or water lines or
other damage to you know property just
from not having proper locates so we are
in the US a huge labor issue um and we
we just finished a study on fiber
deployment cost and somewhere up to 73%
of the cost of fiber deployment is on
labor and so just having um qualified
fiber optic technicians as well as
qualified locators to make sure that
you're digging in the right spot and
know what's before you dig
interesting Bronco um that that's also
after funding has been
uh yeah concentrating a lot of the
attention of the European Union how can
we ensure that deployment is made in in
the best possible way at the lowest
possible cost how can we lower the
barrier uh operational um difficulty to
to get the roll out going as fast as
possible and as cheaply as
possible yes of course we have plenty of
uh of regulatory uh uh actions uh in the
past and also ongoing that are in the
pipeline to be to be
updated um so of of course distinguish
between the two sides as you said in the
beginning so um we have the the gigabit
recommendation which is um uh really
providing guidance to the National
regulatory authorities because you must
know that uh networks are regulated at
the national level of course there is a
kind of board at European level that uh
is both serving to little bit to
harmonize and coordinate the various
nraas and acting as interface with with
us with the commission uh but of course
it's more on the national level that
normally those things are regulated so
we we are doing a recommendation so we
recommend the national regulator
authorities about the conditions to be
imposed on the operator with the with
the strong U significant Market power of
course this is well defined concept um
in order to allow access to their
infrastructure so uh infrastructure
sharing wholesale models that are
already encoded in our main legislation
in the European electronic communication
code they are very much promoted it
doesn't make any sense to have trouble
infrastructure for instance in market
failure rural areas uh it would be
difficult to explain but of course uh in
um Lively Market areas where you have a
lot of population a lot of demand it's
normal to have to have some form of uh
of competition also at the
infrastructure level but of course um uh
we are working on now on an update
version of uh of our current uh our old
leg legislation on the recommendation on
the Next Generation accesss uh
recommendation uh so this is called the
gigabit recommendation which is really
updated to fit for the purpose of of
also of fiber
networks so in these we have various
remedies that we normally apply to the
uh smm SMP operators the the the
dominant operators uh rules for
non-discrimination of course that uh so
so uring equivalence of treatment uh of
access to these infrastructures and how
to monitor these and to follow up and
sure that indeed it is also applied uh
access to civil engineering
infrastructures of the snps the snps
that are somehow obliged to uh share
their their their data about their own
infrastructures um Provisions for of
course um price control and obligations
typically we use the work uh as a
baseline to see uh let's say the the
costing methodology the long long access
pricing and volume discount uh rewarding
on investment risks so we have a number
of methodologies that are really well
encoded in this recommendation which of
course we recommend to the member states
alongside of course Provisions for the
migration to very high capacity networks
and fiber in particular so copper switch
off so this is one side the other side
is what you mentioned okay what can we
do to streamline the deployment of
course on this we have really totally
brand new uh let's say know an update of
the Broadband cost reduction directive I
think in 20124 now it's again adapted to
new to the new new world of 2020
2030 uh and this is called gigabit
infrastructure act which is really in
the last stages of code decision we
normally should have it really
uh in in weeks or few months certainly
before the end of the Mandate and this
is about of course uh regulating access
to the physical infrastructure but here
we look for inance we have Provisions to
O oblige the Public Services to make
available certain physical
infrastructures that are not networks
like for instance a public building to
put to put fiber inside it or to put
simply a 5G uh poll on it because this
is of course embra encompassing not only
fixed network but also the the mobile
networks so accessing access to existing
network infrastructures of other uh
operators under Fair uh reasonable terms
and non-discriminatory conditions
including uh conditions on price so
we um we we have also provision for
streamlining uh and accelerating the
permit granting as well because it's
always a blocking factor or slowing
Factor on that uh so we here the the
important thing is the tasit approval
which is a quite controversial Point
here so if within four months the The
Authority doesn't provide the okay
typically the tasit approval could be
triggered I cannot say will because it's
still formally in under discussion this
is the most controversial part we have
also transparency measures the idea of
creating a single uh information point
or single dashboard where you can go ask
whatever you need as a permit sharing
information between the various type of
infrastructure utilities or whatever so
all of these will be part of our
forthcoming G gigabit infrastructure act
you have seen our proposal but now this
isn't the last stages of before being
voted hopefully hopefully soon you know
way then we can sit together Gary
Eduardo and try to map the differences
and see how we can learn from each other
thank you well thank you Franco and and
indeed uh we're coming to the end of the
session but the the purpose was to give
you an overview of what exists in the
different region it's by definition in
60 minutes is obviously a very high
level but I guess it is also an
encouragement for for whoever is
interested in learning from uh the
experience of the different region in
the globe to to go on on the website of
the different organization of the fiber
um Council Alliance uh you you have the
um you know their names in the in the
presentation or you can reach out to to
any of the association you you're
familiar with to be put in touch with uh
with the other colleagues from the other
side of the ocean I'm sure uh everyone
will will do that with pleasure so I
hope you you found the session
informative and insightful I would like
to to thank uh very much our panel Gary
Eduardo
Franco uh very much appreciate your your
comments your expertise your insights um
and with that I would like to to thank
also our audience for for having
attended the session um I'm sure you
will be invited to many other uh events
and and opportunity to discuss with your
peers uh around this very interesting
topic of ftth deployment and Telecom in
general so thanks so much have a good
rest of your day
goodbye thank you and
bye-bye